Hollywood runs on hype from a project's
earliest conception to its world
premiere and beyond the entire movie
industry depends on getting audiences as
pumped as possible for their blockbuster
product in fact there's an entire
industry within the industry filled with
people whose jobs depend on getting the
word out unfortunately the folks whose
job it is to market an hype of a film
aren't always on the same page as the
people tasked with actually making a
movie announcements are made interviews
are given and all of a sudden the film
just up and disappears from the studio's
release schedule it can happen for all
sorts of surprising reasons but
regardless all were left with is the
disappointment of knowing we'll never
get to see the movie we were promised
here's a look at some overhyped films
that quietly disappeared from the
release schedule dark universe the dark
universe will probably go down in
Hollywood history as a prime example of
the high risk of studio runs of being
embarrassed by overhyped films in an
attempt to mirror the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is interwoven narratives and
massive box office success Universal
Studios look to their own crossover
worthy characters classic monsters like
Dracula the Wolfman and more while it
wouldn't be the first time Universal had
made crossover movies the idea is behind
this new franchise seem to borrow more
from superhero and action movies than
the gothic influences of their early
nineteen hundred's forebears Universal
even invested in a special dark universe
logo to introduce films that would take
place in the universe so what happened
unfortunately despite all start casting
like Tom Cruise in the mummy and Johnny
Depp is the Invisible Man the dark
universe was quickly derailed when the
mummy bombed at the box office
Bride of Frankenstein which was rumored
to star Angelina Jolie in the title role
was quickly taken off of Universal
schedule and despite a massive launch
announcement with a photoshopped lineup
of the stars the creatives behind the
would-be franchise moved on to other
projects it looks like the real dark
universe was ours all along divergent
ascendant the divergent adaptations
seemed like a sure thing based on the
hit young adult novels by Veronica Roth
the dystopian action series seemed like
the natural heir to the Hunger Games
hysteria that dominated the box office
unfortunately while the first two films
managed to earn a respectable return on
investments they weren't quite as
bankable as the studio
might have hoped even so Lionsgate went
forward with splitting the final film
into two like Harry Potter Twilight and
the Hunger Games before it and that
decision turned out to be a huge mistake
Allegiant was only loosely based on the
book version of the same and not only
were the reviews for the film scathing
but fans failed to turn up at the ticket
booth as well as a result the would-be
final film ascendant fell apart at the
seams by losing its director and cast
and then being shunted off to the
television circuit where it's remained
in production limbo World War Z - based
on the gripping bestseller by Max Brooks
World War Z came loaded with a
passionate fan base including some of
Hollywood's most prestigious actors
after a bidding war against Leonardo
DiCaprio's production group Appian Way
Brad Pitt's company Plan B optioned and
produced the film adaptation of the
apocalyptic zombie thriller
unfortunately things started going
downhill from there as the film became
an entirely different kind of disaster
movie after the initial filming process
was complete the flick went through a
massive reshoot process that basically
replaced the film's entire third act and
made it unrecognizable to readers of
Brooks's version although it still went
on to score a solid half billion dollars
at the box office
the film's ballooned production costs
ate into those profits a sequel was
still announced by Paramount Pictures
due to the bounty of book material left
to bring to the big screen we have so
many ideas of so much information that
we think we we got a lot of stuff to
mine from you however the film's release
date has continued to be bumped back
again and again
to the point where it seems like
director David Fincher might never get a
chance to resurrect this franchise
Terminator Genisys - the first
Terminator Genisys left a lot to be
desired
for instance the movie was straight-up
incomplete and basically relied on the
eventual sequel to complete the
narrative unfortunately planning for a
sequel can backfire if the released
movie underperforms and that's exactly
what happened with Genesis the film did
have some serious star power with Emilia
Clarke and the return of Arnold
Schwarzenegger
who made good on that promise I'll be
back however the movie underperformed in
the US and fell short of its production
budget by about 60 million dollars what
was meant to be the birth of a new
trilogy turned out to be a non-starter
and the sec
installment was removed from paramount
upcoming releases paving the way for yet
another adjustment of franchise
continuity with the sequel that would
ignore everything after Judgment Day
fantastic for two years before anyone
seriously believed Marvel Comics could
spin-off anything approaching a
cinematic universe
the venerable publisher fell on hard
Financial Times and ended up selling off
the film rights to some of the most
popular characters Spiderman landed at
Sony and the Fantastic Four and x-men
landed at Fox and without access to
those heroes the fledgling Marvel
Studios turned to characters like Iron
Man Captain America and Thor which were
at the time properties that had never
achieved quite as much mainstream
popularity of course this all ended up
working out pretty well for Marvel and
for Fox and Sony both of whom found
themselves sitting on adaptation options
that had never been more valuable as a
result Spidey and the Fantastic Four
have both spawned multiple franchises
but while Sony has managed to hit
box-office pay dirt with its spider-man
movies on more than one occasion the
Fantastic Four films have had a rougher
go of it
Fox's first pass at the franchise made
money but the reviews were less than
kind prompting a reboot in 2015 and that
attempt fared even worse than its
predecessors earning god-awful reviews
and the worst grosses of any theatrical
release in the series still there's no
benefit to holding film rights you can't
use so Fox executives consistently
reiterated that a sequel was definitely
happening regardless of what happened
with the first film considering the
latest release promised a June 2017
arrival we can pretty safely assume that
the sequel won't be happening the Disney
Fox merger deal might mean that Marvel's
first family will get another shot at a
movie released sometime although it
likely won't be anytime soon and it
won't be a follow-up to any past
Fantastic Four film which is probably
just as well
sinister six Sony didn't just own the
rights to spider-man the studio also
laid claim to an assortment of other
characters related to everybody's
favorite friendly neighborhood web
slinger in order to compete with
Marvel's growing domination of the
superhero genre Sony announced plans in
2014 to make a sinister six movie to be
directed by Drew Goddard the film's
conceit was fairly ambitious bringing
together six of Spidey's most famous
villains together as the titular
supervillain team
promotional materials were even created
to build fan fervour following the
release of the amazing spider-man 2
sadly while everyone seemed invested in
making sinister six of reality the
Amazing Spider sequel underperform
paving the way for a deal between Marvel
and Sony that was struck just in time to
reboot the character again with Tom
Holland in the role and have Spidey make
his Marvel Cinematic Universe debut
alongside Captain America and Iron Man
and Captain America Civil War it led to
all sorts of spider-man goodness but the
collateral damage of the deal included
Goddard's sinister six sony hasn't given
up on Spider spin-offs and although
subsequent plans to continue building
out the characters shared universe have
hit some snags of their own fans can
still look forward to a big-screen solo
outing for at least one of spider-man's
most popular foes uncharted when it
comes to experiences that feel like
watching an Indiana Jones movie and
mostly limited to getting a doctorate in
archeology or going on the Indiana Jones
ride at Disney with still the Uncharted
video game series manages to scratch the
particular itch of watching a handsome
and dashing adventurer run around giant
monuments while flirting with pretty
girls and almost getting killed by
amoral thieves the series follows Nathan
Drake as an artifact hunter whose
adventures in picturesque locations and
grand action set-pieces
seem absolutely made for the big screen
while movie adaptations of video games
tend to be poorly received adapting
Uncharted seemed like a perfect
continuation of the pulpy adventure
movies that Indiana Jones had traded up
unfortunately the movie ran through a
series of difficult turnovers as
director after director left the project
joe carnahan was tapped to write the
script in 2016 but the Uncharted movie
was removed from Sony's upcoming release
lists only a few months later still fans
don't need to lose hope completely a
since deleted Instagram post by Tom
Holland seemed to imply that he would be
starring in the long awaited movie much
like any archaeologist fans will just
have to wait and see if what comes out
of the ground is treasure or trash
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]